[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi avec un focus sur les
métiers de l'audiovisuel
sans oublier notre volet est consacré à
la formation
voici le sommaire jr ou encore
réalisateur dans ce numéro découverte de
ces métiers présents dans le secteur de
l'audiovisuel
nous irons à plaisir où est implantée
l'entreprise seces prod vous découvrirez
également les coulisses du journal de
télé 78 pour se former à ce métier nous
prendrons la direction a des longs cours
la fomac centre de formation d'apprentis
pour cause notamment un bts audiovisuel
une formation de deux ans en alternance
ce sont des métiers où la routine est
rarement au rendez-vous l'audiovisuel
est un secteur qui attire en lien avec
le cinéma ou bien avec la télévision
elle les professions sont multiples que
ce soit sur le terrain ou bien en
coulisses
nous nous sommes rendus à plaisir dans
une agence de production audiovisuelle
et puis pour ce numéro et bien vous
allez découvrir l'envers du décor de tv
soit 118 je ne vous en dis pas plus
reportage nous sommes à plaisir c'est
ici que sont installés les locaux de
16,16 prod
cette agence de production et de
communication audiovisuelle a été créé
en 2006
david martin bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le gérant de 16,16 prod alors quel type
d'activité ont fait ici et à ccs prod
vous fait du film du film et de la
communication audiovisuelle au sens
large c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est clip
reportages documentaires émissions ont
fait des directs enfin voilà on fait
vraiment à absolument tout pour des
collectivités des entreprises sur tout
le territoire saint quentin en yvelines
voire même au delà ou au delà au delà on
est très implantée sur la région
parisienne mais on travaille beaucoup
avec la région centre avec nord avec
l'est aussi
voilà donc on est pas mal étalé sur une
grande moitié nord de la france sur une
année à peu près vous vous fait combien
de production ont fait à peu près 400
films par an alors quand j'appelle quand
je dis film c'est aussi un petit
reportage de deux minutes trois minutes
ça c'est un produit
et puis il ya des films un peu plus
qu'on sent conséquent qui reprennent
toute une année pour une collectivité
[Musique]
sinon bonjour bonjour ça fait vraiment
que vous êtes jerry ici au 100 brasse
société cesse prod alors pourquoi vous
avez choisi de faire ce métier
en fait jean marie cursus journalisme et
au sein de ce cursus j'ai pu j'ai pu
travailler pendant quelques mois en tant
que stagiaire chez ma chaîne étudiante
et c'est un petit peu à ce moment là que
je suis tombé amoureux de la caméra et
tout ça et voilà au fur et à mesure j'ai
voulu sortir un peu du voile du profil
journalistes pour intéresser plus
précisément à au travail et de l'image
en fait si vous vous faites quoi quels
sont vos missions quotidiennes alors
beaucoup de reportages beaucoup de
montage
je suis amené parfois écrire des
scénarios je suis amené à faire aussi de
la réalisation sur des directs
c'est super varié en fait alors qu'est
ce qui vous plaît finalement dans ce
métier la recherche de l'esthétisme je
pense c'est quelque chose qui m'attire
travail et une image pour essayer de
faire ressortir une émotion
voilà c'est ce qui me plaît c'est aussi
le fait de de l'iem musique et images en
fait jusque là va rarement sans l'autre
[Musique]
comme tous les soirs à 18h du lundi au
jeudi c'est parti pour le 7-8 journal 25
minutes d'information locale en direct
qui demande la mobilisation de plusieurs
personnes des journalistes mais aussi
des monteurs chargé de mettre en images
les sujets des spécialistes du son ou
encore des réalisateurs après un bac
électrotechnique une formation
audiovisuelle à l'école troisième des
longs cours
romain est aux commandes de ce rendez
vous quotidien depuis six saisons
quand le journaliste est en plateau et
doit à la fois lancer les sujets et
faire ces entretiens
derrière le derrière la caméra ou
derrière les manettes il y à un
réalisateur qui lui met en images tout
ça en direct avec toutes les sources
caméra qu'il a à disposition plus les
sujets et les et tout ce qui est
éléments vidéos qui ont été montés par
les monteurs la journée et on mais on
essaie de faire un mélange de tout ça
pour qu'à l'antenne ça rende
le résultat le mieux possible une
concentration de tous les instants une
des qualités indispensables pour ce
métier mais accueille tout ce qui est
préparation qui vient en amont c'est
justement ce qui permet en étant
organisés en étant structuré d'avoir le
moins de surprises possibles au moment
où tout se dire déroule direct parce que
le direct fait qu' on n'a pas forcément
l'esprit clair pour réagir mieux on est
préparé plus ce sera facile de trouver
une solution parce qu'on aura déjà
préparer des solutions de secours au cas
où il ya un problème qui se passe une
chose est sûre vous ne regarderez plus
votre journal de la même façon alors
vous l'avez bien sûr compris ces métiers
sont tous technique et demande une
formation particulière depuis septembre
à elancourt il est possible de suivre en
alternance en bts audiovisuel techniques
d'ingénierie et exploitation des
équipements
cette formation est proposée par l'afo
mavs et accueille une quinzaine
d'apprentis installé sur le plus grand
campus audiovisuel d'europe à elancourt
à l'info mavs l'association de formation
aux métiers de l'audiovisuel est un
centre de formation d'apprentis
il propose trois diplômes technicien
projectionniste technicien spectacle
événementiel est ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui un bts audiovisuel grégoire
boulant bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
référent bts audiovisuel ici à la faux
mavs
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter ce
diplôme cette formation oui donc le bts
audiovisuel est une formation supérieure
en deux ans
ici à la forme avoue nous sommes dans un
centre de formation en alternance
il ya donc un rythme particulier puisque
les étudiants sont la moitié du temps
d'entreprise et l'autre moitié à l'école
on va toucher autant aux sons qu'à
l'image on va former des
les jeunes pour travailler en régie pour
travailler pour sur des chaînes de télé
mais également chez pourquoi pas des
loueurs de matériel c'est des
techniciens polyvalents qui connaissent
bien la chaîne de production et qui
connaissent tous les aspects de
l'audiovisuel que ce soit la prise de
son la prise de vue la réalisation la
postproduction le montage le mixage
il doit vraiment avoir une vision
globale de l'audiovisuel au bout de ces
deux ans est-ce qu'ils sont assurés
d'avoir de trouver un emploi
grossièrement on en a un sur trois qui
restent dans son entreprise et qui est
engagée soit en cdd soient en cdi
on en a un autre tiers qui va les
trouver du boulot dans une autre
entreprise
et puis et bien sûr l'intermittence donc
on a aussi des jeunes qui décident
voilà de travailler tantôt pour
l'instant tant pour l'autre on sait bien
que dans les métiers de l'audiovisuel
beaucoup de techniciens sont
intermittents et sont amenés à avoir
plusieurs employeurs
j'ai commencé un cursus en droit qui m'a
pas du tout plu en fait je suis
clairement trompé en allant dans cette
filière puis par la suite je me suis dis
simplement que je voulais travailler et
vivre de ma passion qui est l
audiovisuel alors est ce que vous nous
en dire plus sur sur les courts que vous
suivez ici donc est la théorie il ya
aussi beaucoup de pratique j'imagine
c'est ça qui vous séduit aussi dans
cette eau dans cette formation
c'est exactement ça qui m'a kim avait
charmé au début et qui même ses rivales
s'est révélée par la suite c'est que au
début j'avais des compétences qui
étaient très théorique que j'avais fait
en autodidacte et je voulais
des cours qui soit beaucoup plus
pratique être au contact du matériel
pour moi c'est la meilleure école que
faire des cures h 24 tandis que là on a
des cours qui sont très variés on a
beaucoup de cours théoriques mais on a
aussi beaucoup de cours pratiques ce qui
permet de varier un maximum et que à la
fin qu'on sorte du cursus on est le
package comme je l'appelle pour être
prêt au milieu de l'audiovisuel alors là
vous êtes en première année donc il vous
reste encore une année supplémentaire à
faire pour valider votre bts
est ce que vous savez déjà ce que vous
voulez faire là évidemment travailler
dans l'audiovisuel mais ce que vous avez
déjà une idée précise ou pas encore là
on est dans un cursus qui est très varié
très complet mais par la suite il va
falloir se spécialiser et quand je vous
serez spécialisé je partirai pour moi
mon saint graal comme je l'appelle le
cinéma chaque année la fondation remet
une soixantaine d'élèves la plupart
d'entre eux trouvent un emploi à l'issue
de leur formation
voilà vous en savez plus ce désormais
sur les métiers de l'audiovisuel voici
ce qu'il faut retenir
alors ce soir vous avez pu découvrir le
métier de jerry journaliste reporter
d'image avec simon pour exercer cette
profession il faut notamment suivre une
formation dans une école de journalisme
en deux ou cinq ans après le bac pour la
rémunération alors la fourchette est
évidemment large selon les structures
alors pour un autre exemple dans cette
agence de production audiovisuelle à
plaisir comptez en moyenne 1700 euros
nets
l'évolution dans ce métier rédacteur en
chef la qualité indispensable être
disponible deuxième métiers présentés
dans cette émission réalisateur d'un
journal télé une formation de minimum 2
ans après le bac dans une école
d'audiovisuel est nécessaire
la rémunération dépend là aussi de la
taille de la structure cela peut aller
de 1500 euros net à plus de 4000 euros
par mois voire même beaucoup plus
l'évolution possible dans ce métier
réalisateur producteur et puis la
qualité indispensable pour durer dans le
métier être organisé voilà cette
émission touche bientôt à sa fin mais
avant on va voir ensemble les rendez
vous alliez à l'emploi qui vous
attendent
mercredi 14 mars à partir de 9h30 un job
dating mécanicien est organisée à la
cité des métiers attrape une inscription
est nécessaire au 01 34 81
82 61 et n'oubliez pas bien sûr votre cv
jeudi 15 mars de 17h à 21h l'entreprise
assystem technologie organise également
un job dating 2000 postes d'ingénieurs
ou encore de techniciens sont à pourvoir
sur toute la france alors ce job dating
tour se déroule à montigny le bretonneux
il faut s'inscrire par mail à job dating
@ à systems.com mercredi à 21 mars de
9h30 à midi a lieu une matinée
d'information sur la reconversion
professionnelle intitulé déclic
formation afpa c'est à la cité des
métiers à trappes
inscription au 01 34 82 82 61 et puis un
rendez-vous qui approche de plus en plus
ce jeudi 29 mars de 10 heures à 22
heures a lieu en piste pour l'emploi un
événement gratuit au vélodrome nationale
mais pour lequel il faut s'inscrire sur
le www.skype.com r voilà c'est la fin de
ce mode d'emploi merci de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve le mardi 27 mars pour un
nouveau numéro
à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]